bienvenidos en el vídeo anterior
mostramos que cualquier presión externa
sobre un líquido en un contenedor se
distribuye de forma homogénea en todo el
líquido ya esto se le llama principio de
pascal pero esto solo aplica a presiones
externas ahora veamos lo que respecta a
la presión interna y creo que varios de
nosotros estamos familiarizados con el
concepto de que mientras más profundo lo
sumergimos en el agua más presión
tendremos o sentiremos vemos y podemos
ver esto de un modo más analítico y
tener un marco de referencia para
comprender qué es la presión dentro o en
las profundidades del agua o en algún
otro líquido aquí he dibujado un
cilindro y dentro de él tenemos un
fluido asumo que esto esté en un planeta
con la misma masa de la tierra pero sin
su atmósfera por lo que aquí afuera hay
un vacío así que no hay presión por
parte de la atmósfera pero si la misma
gravedad y la misma constante
gravitacional
dentro de este cilindro tengo una
delgada hoja de aluminio que cubre por
completo esta área del cilindro y lo
hice para tener un indicador de cuando
el agua sube o baja digamos que tengo
esto dentro de un fluido a una
profundidad h y ya que el fluido está
completamente quieto este objeto que se
encuentra a este nivel también estará
estático y para que algo está estático o
no se está moviendo que sabemos al
respecto bueno sabemos que las fuerzas
netas sobre él son cero por lo que mi
fuerza hacia abajo
fuerza le voy a poner d
va a ser igual que mi fuerza hacia
arriba que le voy a poner efe
por lo que f de es igual a efe
y cuál es la fuerza efe de que está
actuando sobre este cilindro bueno pues
va a ser el peso del líquido que se
encuentra arriba ya que tenemos gravedad
y este líquido tiene masa por lo que
cualquiera que sea la masa multiplicada
por la gravedad va a ser igual a ésta
efe así que vamos a calcular su valor
efe
es igual a la vamos a poner el azulito
la masa del líquido
la gravedad esto de acá es mi masa del
líquido
y veamos cuál es la masa del líquido y
aquí les presento un concepto nuevo
llamado densidad que es algo así como
que qué tanta cantidad de algo hay en un
volumen dado la letra griega que se usa
para densidad es rock vamos a ponerlo en
un bonito color naranja
aunque a mí me parece más una p
así que la densidad es igual a la masa
massa entre el volumen
volumen
y esto es igual si tomamos las unidades
de medida de cada uno a kilogramos /
metros cúbicos
esto es densidad aunque muchos de
nosotros tenemos el entendimiento del
concepto por ejemplo sabemos que el
plomo es más denso que los malvaviscos y
si yo tuviera un metro cúbico de plomo
éste tendría más masa que un metro
cúbico de malvavisco los mismos lo que
es la densidad y regresemos a nuestro
planteamiento nos quedamos en que
queremos conocer la masa del líquido que
se encuentra por encima de mi placa y
usando la fórmula de densidad podemos
decir que la masa va a ser igual a
densidad
por volumen
sustituyendo esto en la fórmula nos va a
quedar que f
la fuerza de arriba va a ser igual a
no
el volumen que es la altura por el área
por la gravedad
y ahora tratemos de encontrar la presión
en esta sección intermedia que es
nuestra interrogante inicial la presión
es igual a la fuerza sobre el área así
que vamos a dividir esta fórmula entre
el área recordamos que el área base es
esta base de misil indro esto es a si yo
divido esta fórmula entre a
/ a
voy a quitar esto de aquí y me va a
quedar que la fuerza de arriba de lo que
está aquí arriba es rojo por altura por
la gravedad y sabemos también que la
presión de arriba va a ser igual a la
presión de abajo entonces sabemos que la
presión de arriba es igual a la presión
de abajo porque sus respectivas fuerzas
son iguales lo sabemos de esta de este
enunciado de otra manera esta sección de
aluminio se estaría moviendo ahora
usamos esto para realizar un ejemplo
imaginemos que el líquido es agua y la
densidad del agua y este es un buen dato
para recordar la densidad del agua la
voy a poner en azul también la densidad
del agua es igual a 1000
kilogramos sobre metro cúbico parece que
no pero el agua es bastante densa y voy
a sumergirme 10 metros
a 10 metros de profundidad entonces mi
altura en este ejemplo es 10 metros la
presión si sustituimos estos datos vamos
a tener que la presión
va a ser igual
mmm
x
por la gravedad que es la misma que
tenemos en la tierra 9.8 metros sobre
segundo al cuadrado y si hacemos esta
operación nos va a quedar que la presión
va a ser igual a 98 mil pascal es lo que
parece mucho pero en realidad no lo es
tanto de hecho esto es casi igual a la
presión de nuestra atmósfera a nivel del
mar nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo